[Music]
foreign
this brand new smartphone from 2023 has
a six and a half inch 90 Hertz display
with a hole punch cut out a 5 000
milliamp hour battery triple cameras a
Micro SD card slot for expandable
storage a headphone jack and water
resistance for 169.
but what's the catch there's got to be a
catch right so look I've said it before
and I'll say it again good phones are
getting cheap
yeah and cheap phones are getting good
and this video is going to focus on the
second part of that which is the cheap
phones that are getting so good because
this phone hit my inbox recently it's
called the Moto G play for 2023 and he's
been paying attention to what Motorola
has been doing recently they've been
making a lot of really good budget
phones in the background for the past
couple years I just wanted to know
personally from using it myself how do
you end up at a phone that's a tenth of
the price of the ones that I've been
really enjoying so on the outside well
it's a pretty big phone which I like and
there's actually a 6.5 inch flat 90
Hertz LCD display now it's not the best
looking screen you've ever seen it's
only 720p so I can literally see pixel
sometimes and it doesn't get very bright
you know viewing angles are pretty bad
if you get off axis and of course the
bezels you can see are slightly thicker
especially in the chin and there's this
little bit of light fall off around the
hole punch camera at the top but the
thing is like can you really pixel peep
at this price like this is plenty of
screen for texting web browsing
navigation you know flipping through
apps scrolling through social media the
classic stuff you want to do on a phone
mission accomplished you know it's a big
screen so that's not the catch but what
about the build you've probably picked
up that it's a pretty big phone but it's
also made of plastic but honestly the
layout is perfectly fine like you've got
the port and the speakers at the bottom
there's a headphone jack at the top and
you have bonus expandable storage
alongside the SIM card tray right where
it belongs and on the back yes that is a
decently fast fingerprint reader right
in that classic Motorola dimple spot so
it's laid out well it absolutely does
not Bend or Creak or anything weird like
that plus you might have heard plastic
is absolutely not the end of the world
when it comes to a smartphone build
obviously the premium ones will really
like to feel more premium and heavy and
so glass will do that but this is often
more durable than glass if you drop it
and some people like a lighter weight
phone when it is this big also it is
still water resistant I can't say
waterproof it's ip52 but it's water
resistant and so the build that's not
the catch so okay what about the battery
you might be wondering cheap phone it's
excellent perfectly unironically not
exaggerating it's excellent which
actually shouldn't be a surprise given
the spec it's a 5 000 milliamp hour
battery powering a phone with a 720p
display so you're good for a day and a
half easy two light days is no problem
with seven hours of screen on time now
it's only up to 10 watt charging which
is pretty slow and there is no wireless
charging but I'm not going to consider
that a gotcha at this price again it's
like you can just charge it up overnight
every night like a normal person and
battery life will be fine and even the
software is really good it's virtually
the same experience as their thousand
dollar Flagship Edge phone which is to
say near stock Android with a little
Moto extra features sprinkled on top so
at its most basic it'll kind of feel
like a pixel when you dig through like
quick settings and notifications on the
launcher but then you get some Motorola
widgets tucked in you know you get a
couple extra settings in the settings
app but then you get this Moto app that
lets you dig into your X extra gestures
and features that they've perfected over
the years the double chop for the
flashlight the three finger screenshot
you know the peak display feature that
gives you a peek at your new
notifications and even swiping down on
your notification panel from the
fingerprint reader on the back basically
everything minus the double twist to
quickly open the camera probably because
the camera is not one of those things
that you really look forward to on these
super cheap phones oh wow look at the
light fall off you can see it on camera
but either way I'm happy to report that
this camera is
functional which is like that's what you
would hope for at this price which is
yeah it's it's functional I'm just not a
huge fan of the triple camera layout
here like I know they're trying to look
premium and triple cameras looks premium
but the top one is a two megapixel macro
camera and the bottom one is a two
megapixel depth camera for portrait mode
so I'm mainly just looking for this main
16 megapixel camera to be able to
capture scenes documents you know take
photos and videos without problems and
it does especially if you give it enough
light uh it's not going to win any
comparison tests that's for sure but hey
we ask a lot of our phones like the fact
that this 169 dollar Gadget can already
make phone calls and send text messages
and navigate you around the world and
also play games and also browse the web
and it can also take decent pictures and
1080p videos and that's solid I
initially had my suspicions about
whether or not it was going to actually
use this depth camera when I take a
portrait mode photo but it did yell at
me when I covered it and tried to take a
portrait mode shot so it's paying
attention to it at least but when I took
the photo and turned up the background
blur this is the cutout shape which if
you zoom in just a little bit is truly
bizarre it's really bad I've never seen
anything this bad in my life it really
just said yeah we'll just save a little
processing power here and use the zigzag
cut out method from those scissors from
preschool to make this work but see
that's the thing that is the catch it's
not the build quality that's fine and
it's definitely not the battery life
that's great it's not the cameras and
it's certainly not the software
it's that this phone is slow really slow
so this phone has a mediatek helio G37
chip inside and three gigabytes of RAM
other phones with this chipset include
the Techno spark 9 the infinix hot 12
and the honor x7a all of which retail
well under 150 U.S so clearly it's a
cheap chip right and that's how it ended
up in this phone for some context the
geekbench score of the iPhone 14 is this
and the geekbench score of the Moto G
play is this so when I say it's trying
to save processing power by not really
doing detailed portrait cutouts I
actually mean that like it absolutely
lacks any meaningful processing power
and I'm not nitpicking about like maybe
it's just slow on some high-end games or
something no this phone is slow all the
time it's slow to scroll and just like
move around the UI now remember I
mentioned at the beginning that this
phone has a variable 90 Hertz display
but I'll be honest it would have taken
me a while to tell because it is almost
never anywhere near 60 hertz it's
constantly hanging up and stuttering at
everywhere it's slow to unlock it's slow
to open apps not just huge apps just
normal apps even the settings app takes
an embarrassingly long time to open and
even longer to search through things
some of this is like speed of storage as
well to be fair so I don't want to put
it all on the chip but like the point
here is it's it's absolutely the catch
this phone is slower than average to
take pictures it's slow to type stuff to
browse around and just to do anything
like high-end gaming or photo editing is
kind of out of the question it might be
the slowest phone I've ever used and I'm
constantly reminded of it which can make
it quite unpleasant to use so the longer
I use this phone the more it had me
thinking about one big question which is
is it better to get a brand new cheap
phone like this or an older formerly
expensive Flagship one like this one
this is 169 brand new right this phone
here this is the OnePlus 7 Pro you might
remember it it's one of my favorite
phones ever this was the phone of the
year in 2019 so this was 669 back when
it came amount but it can be had easily
for well under 200 right now second hand
so this is just one example of a phone
like this this phone if you compare a
dollar for dollar with the Moto is just
so much better of an experience across
the board obviously it'll have a much
better chipset so Snapdragon 855 is a
few years old but it's much more capable
and part of an overall smoother better
performance profile with faster storage
and more RAM it has a much much nicer
OLED screen which is sharper brighter
and actually hits the 90 Hertz refresh
rate all the time it has way more
built-in storage although it's not
expandable and it has a much better set
of cameras it's a primary plus an ultra
wide and a zoom and it's built from
glass instead of plastic which feels
Rock Solid and it has a 4 000 milliamp
hour battery which is probably the only
Hardware line you can call it a draw or
maybe even a win for the Moto phone but
we can't forget that warp charging that
OnePlus was famous for so this little
Flagship will do 30 watts of wired
charging so it's semen pretty unanimous
here but one distinctive advantage of
the budget phone is because it's new it
will get software updates further into
the future than the old phone now this
is theoretically of course like Motorola
does not have the best track record here
so it depends on what phone we're
talking about but the Samsung A14 5G for
example has a pretty similar spec sheet
and a similar price point and that'll
probably get more software updates than
the Moto but the idea here is even if a
flagship phone is Promised three to four
years of software updates and the budget
phone is only getting two as soon as
that flagship phone is more than about
three years old it doesn't have that
Advantage anymore so the OnePlus 7 Pro
is probably about done with software
updates while we probably have a few in
the tank for the Moto it is also funny
though sometimes how I hear people talk
about software updates like some people
don't think about software updates at
all they avoid software updates don't do
that by the way the security patches are
actually pretty important but yeah it's
just one of those points that has to by
default go to the newer phone but the
final straw in favor of the older phone
is actually the environment just because
buying an older phone that's built to
last and getting an extra two three four
years out of it potentially is better
for the environment overall you buy less
new things it's less E-Waste so that's
something that's a feather and the cap
of the old phone over the new one so my
general thought as I've looked at this
landscape and all these options with old
flagships versus new budget phones is
the lower the price of the phone the
more I would actually want to buy the
older phone so at 169 for example based
on the experience I've had with this
phone I would definitely rather have
actually the older flagship phone
there's a lot of flagships you can get
at about 200 bucks you could get this
one you could get a pixel 5 Second Hand
phones are really good now if you go up
to like 400 bucks then it's a little
more debatable there's still some things
that would still Point me towards the
formerly flagship phone but then you get
to like 600 bucks and it's like oh
there's really good brand new 600 phones
that I would take today and still have
the event manages of the software
updates it's not a lot that's better
than the pixel 7 right now so that's the
theory so there you have it at this
price point I'd prefer prehistoric
premium over presently pleasantly priced
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace
[Music]
pleasantly present that's a lot
pleasantly present presently pleasantly
priced